I mentioned uh the things that you do
whenever I introduce you but I left one
out I heard that you are a pickleball
club owner yes I do own a pickleball
Club
yes I've never played me neither
[Laughter]
what I know wait you've never played no
I figured you could teach me okay no I
play paddle tennis
ping pong or well paddle tennis is um
not normal tennis no it's like in a
smaller court and has Glass Walls it's
not racquetball okay I was gonna say and
it's not pickle it's a lot of sports in
there yeah that we mentioned okay I know
I know I've never played either I've
heard it's really fun though it is super
fun and pickleball's super fun from what
I gather yeah
um I like watching it I watch it those
players are crazy good okay so the
you go and watch because it's not like a
beginner's thing no no these are
professional pickleball oh yeah yeah I
own a league down down in Santa Monica
yeah no this is like a professional
League it just started okay okay big
thing anybody play I want to try yeah
I've never tried everybody talks about
it we should try I like it we should do
it next time okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm going